here in nevada governor sysolak says our
state will follow the cdc's new
guidelines about ditching the mask
indoors if you're fully vaccinated 8
news now reporter victoria saha taking a
look at how some businesses
and residents feel it's been nearly 15
months of having to wear masks wherever
we go
but these signs of mask requirements
that a lot of businesses have
may disappear soon yes i'm very excited
to get back to normal i think it will
bring the business
a lot more you know a lot more busier at
bellia beauty spa the owner says despite
the cdc's new guidelines
her team will still keep their guard up
because there's no way for them to know
who's fully vaccinated so far i don't
think i have any right to just
constantly asking people you know i
don't think it's
you know but we just protect ourselves
when we're in the room one-on-one with
the client we wear our mess others say
the masks benefit them during quarantine
was the first time that
i didn't get sick like in the entire
year
and normally i get sick when the weather
changes stuff like that i feel like
honestly it's been pretty great wearing
a mask
jane lee is a permanent makeup artist
getting rid of the masks is not
something she will be doing anytime soon
i literally just told my client right
now that i wanted them to continue
wearing masks because i feel like
in the beauty world that we're going to
keep consistently being so close to each
other
even for those fully vaccinated some say
the mask
is extra protection i'm a plan to keep
keep it sanitized wearing my mask
indoors
at all times even now that i'm fully
vaccinated almost year and a half ordeal
of
covid taking over and changing so many
lives
i just feel like it's best to continue
wearing it as a precaution
victoria saha 8 news now